we all loved him we all miss him he
saved the universe the one and only Iron
Man how's it going everyone it's Warren
and although everybody is heartbroken
that Iron Man is out of the MCU now
because he sacrificed himself to save
the universe and Avengers endgame we do
have a bit of really great news today as
we have learned that Robert Downey jr.
will be returning to the MCU to reprise
his role as Iron Man this report is
coming from deadline.com and yes it is
super exciting news but before you get
too excited he is not coming back at a
point in time in the MCU that is after
avengers endgame he is coming back and
phase four but not in a movie that takes
place after Avengers in game in a movie
that takes place before so I'll break
down what deadline said in a recent
report stating that Robert Downey jr. is
going to be returning to the MCU as Iron
Man quick reminder the 500,000
subscriber giveaway winner has been
chosen and contacted but I'm doing
another giveaway at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers doing the
same giveaway giving away an Xbox one or
a ps4 all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain also if you'd like
a chance to win a Nintendo switch be
sure to click the link in the
description down below so like I said
according to Deadline comm Robert Downey
jr. is returning to the MCU to play Iron
Man but this does not mean that he is
coming back to life
according to Deadline comms report they
said Downey will be seen in the role of
stark one more time however in the
Marvel prequel Black Widow in May 2020
and obviously we know that Black Widow
is going to be set in the past right
after the events of Captain America
Civil War so Tony Stark / Iron Man is
going to be returning to the MCU just
not in the way that everybody would like
him to be but at least we get to see him
one last time in an MCU film and
honestly it probably won't be the last
time he'll probably make an appearance
somehow in the future probably with AI
and it makes sense that he would have
somewhat of an appearance in the Black
Widow movie he was a major part of civil
war obviously and Black Widow is going
to take place right after the events of
Civil War
Natasha went on the run after Civil War
she went on the run with Captain America
and Falcon but she was still on
good terms with Tony during the events
of Civil War and after after all she did
fight on Iron Man's side ultimately she
let Steve Rogers and Bucky get away
which is why she had to go on the run
but Tony of course knew why she did it
so it would make sense that he would try
to contact her at some point in time
after these events took place it's
probably only going to be a very small
cameo but we do get to see Tony Stark /
Iron Man in the MCU one more time
according to Deadline in Black Widow
even though Iron Man isn't returning for
good this is still very exciting new so
let me know what you think about this
are you excited to see tony stark return
to the big screen one more time in the
MCU be sure to let me know in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe to my channel like
the video and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
xbox one and ps4 giveaway and if you'd
like a chance to win a Nintendo switch
be sure to click the link in the
description down below as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof